foreign
[Music]
from the Pokemon company
today February 27th is Pokemon day
this is the date that the Pokemon Red
and Pokemon green games were first
released in Japan
marking the beginning of the Pokemon
series
at the time only 151 Pokemon had been
discovered
but now that number has grown to over
one thousand
[Music]
to all you trainers around the world who
have journeyed together with your
Pokemon over the years
we are so thankful for your support
in today's presentation
we will be bringing you all sorts of
news about Pokemon
first we would like to talk about this
year's Pokemon world championships the
first ever to be held in Japan
Mr Chris Brown Take it Away
Vita
hello Pokemon trainers I'm Chris Brown
from the Pokemon company International
and I'm so glad to join you again to
talk about our annual Pokemon World
Championships this past year in London
more than 10 000 trainers from all over
the world gather together to celebrate
Pokemon and experience epic battles
thank you to all the trainers who made
the London World Championships our
largest ever and congratulations again
to our newest world champions now I'd
like to share with you all some details
about our next event the 2023 Pokemon
World Championships will be held in
Japan for the very first time we look
forward to trainers battling in the
Pokemon scarlet and Pokemon Violet games
the Pokemon trading card game Pokemon go
and Pokemon unite from August 11th to
13th at the Pacifico Yokohama
for more than a decade we have created
special artwork to honor each location
that makes the world championship
experience unique today I am happy to
share the key art for Yokohama for the
very first time let's have a look
[Music]
[Applause]
the World Championships is so special
because of how our community from around
the world comes together to play Pokemon
we can't wait to see you there and for
those that can't make it be sure to
catch all the action on our live
broadcast all weekend long
thank you
[Music]
thank you Mr Brown
we can't wait to see everyone together
in Yokohama later this year
moving on please have a look at this
video
[Music]
foreign
this morning
Pokemon Trading Card Game classic is
designed to be a premium Pokemon TCG set
that will last a lifetime
created by the design firm nindo
creatures
and the Pokemon company as a joint
production
we'll be providing a sneak peek of the
product at the Pokemon world
championships
so I hope you will all come check it out
next
we'd like to announce a new Pokemon
venture
to tell you more we have Miss Min young
Kim from Netflix
thank you for the kind introduction hi
everyone my name is min young Kim and I
oversee Netflix filming series from Asia
Pacific
thank you for having us here today and
I'm thrilled to share how we're bringing
Pokemon and Netflix together for the
first time this year
at Netflix we're passionate about
developing local programming that
entertains audiences around the world
and so today we're pleased to announce
that Netflix in collaboration with the
Pokemon company are producing a brand
new Netflix series the Pokemon concierge
we have a group of experts here in Japan
who are passionate about finding and
developing Original Stories from Japan
that can excite audiences all over the
world
and we are dedicated to adapting fan
favorite stories and manga into
extraordinary shows
with this title we're excited to marry
an entirely new storyline that expands
the Pokemon Universe with groundbreaking
stop-motion animation
to bring this new world to life we've
partnered with the amazing creative team
at dwarf Studio
the series which will be set at the
Pokemon Resort follows a story of our
considered Haru and the many Pokemon who
visit as guests
we hope you enjoyed today's first look
at the Netflix series Pokemon concert
and we can't wait to share more with you
Pokemon
thank you very much Miss Kim
Pokemon concierge will be a new animated
series brought to you by Netflix and
Pokemon
please stay tuned for this new series
release
now we'd like to present the latest news
about our games
[Music]
Mr utsanomia please take it away
hello I'm utsunomiya from the Pokemon
company
[Music]
have you all been making good progress
with your treasure hunt in the paldea
region
today we have updates on the Pokemon
scarlet and Pokemon Violet games
[Music]
but first please take a look at the
latest updates about several of our
other games
the five on five strategic Team Battle
game Pokemon Unite
we've entered our second year of service
and surpassed 100 million total
downloads
more and more Pokemon have joined The
Fray allowing for even more strategies
and ways to play
[Music]
the legendary Pokemon zashian is now
joining unite battles
its unite move is Sovereign soar
it can cut a broad swath with its slash
attack it can also charge its sword with
EOS energy to unleash a stronger attack
use these huge attacks to overwhelm your
opponents
and don't miss out on special haul aware
the adventure in zashian's wheeled event
is now underway
complete missions to receive Rewards
you can also obtain zashian's unite
license so be sure to join in
there's also a Boss Rush Event underway
stand against formidable foes with your
allies and earn rewards
plus to celebrate Pokemon day we're
Distributing a gift code for a special
item
and we're hosting an invitation only
League to decide our Asia region
Champions check out how the battles are
going on the official Pokemon unite
social channel the teams that win their
way through each league will come
together in a dramatic Face-Off in
Malaysia's Kuala Lumpur on March 18th
and 19th look forward to Asia's greatest
unite battles and will keep bringing you
more to enjoy in Pokemon unite in the
future
[Music]
thank you
what's this seems the aroma of our
newest dish has brought some customers
to the cafe here at the cafe in the
Pokemon cafe remix game we meet Pokemon
from the paldea region sprigatido
fuecoco and quaxley whip up plenty of
servings of the new paldaya dish and
bring Delight to your Pokemon visitors
progress through the event and you'll be
able to choose one of these three to
join your staff which one will you
choose
to celebrate Pokemon day in Pokemon cafe
remix we're also giving away a special
in-game great chef outfit for Greninja
and there's more you can now deliver to
a whole array of five star Chef Pokemon
that have appeared in the past to
celebrate this special development you
can enjoy a bonus 11 times express
delivery right now without using in-game
currency play Pokemon cafe remix on
Nintendo switch or your mobile device
and discover what new Pokemon and
outfits may show up in your Cafe next
I hope you're ready
Here We Come Those with the strongest
convictions will win I'm not gonna let
you win
Shine On
Shall We Begin
mystery at what let's go come on all
right
my wish is for gal lost trainers to work
together to become the strongest in all
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to be as strong as late no I'm
gonna be even stronger
[Music]
[Applause]
paying his all well and good I suppose
but I think I'll cover you in the color
of B
[Music]
show you the power of spite
I want to be the one who beats the
unbeatable champion
let's get this started
[Music]
[Applause]
is
moving on please have a look at this
video
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
la la la la la la la la
good morning
[Music]
foreign
we know we've kept you all waiting
but at last we can bring Pokemon sleep
to you later this year
the idea behind Pokemon sleep is to be a
game that makes you look forward to
waking up in the morning to get a better
idea of what you can expect please check
out the next video
welcome to the world of Pokemon sleep
[Music]
your adventure takes place on a small
island
on this island you'll find great big
Snorlax
and Professor Neroli who is researching
Pokemon sleep
it's easy to play on this island
all you have to do is get a good night's
sleep if you leave your smartphone by
your pillow when you go to bed
your sleep will be measured recorded and
analyzed
once that's done it will be categorized
into one of three sleep types dozing
snoozing or slumbering
Pokemon that tend to sleep in the same
way as you did will gather around
Snorlax
sub you might even discover some rare
in-game sleep styles that most will
never see it seems that each species of
Pokemon has several sleep styles
get lots of sleep and try to find them
all
enjoy going to sleep and waking up each
day as you research the Sleep styles of
Pokemon together with Snorlax
by using the Pokemon sleep app regularly
you can have fun while tracking the
regularity of your sleep or rest rhythm
Pokemon sleep will be available for IOS
and Android devices later this year
next we'd like to introduce the device
you just got a glimpse of the Pokemon go
plus plus
this is the Pokemon go plus plus
accessory it is a new device that you
can use with Pokemon sleep and Pokemon
go
it's very simple to use it with Pokemon
sleep
press the button when you are going to
bed
and press that button once again when
you wake up in the morning
[Music]
just like that your sleep data has been
measured
There's a pikachu within your Pokemon go
plus plus
it can sing you lullabies
[Music]
grow friendlier the more sleep you get
together even unlock new alarm sounds
for you it's like you're cuddled up to
catch some z's with Pikachu
this device also has handy functions for
playing Pokemon go
without even pulling out your smartphone
you can automatically Spin pokestops and
throw regular pokeballs at Pokemon and
now you can choose to throw great balls
and Ultra Balls as well at the Press of
a button
there are future plans to add new
functionality that'll use your sleep
data in Pokemon go 2. stay tuned for
more
what do you think
the Pokemon go plus plus device should
be available to purchase in July and by
linking the Pokemon go plus plus to your
Pokemon Go game you'll get access to
special research in Pokemon go that will
allow you to encounter a Snorlax wearing
a night cap
look forward to more news to come about
Pokemon sleep and the Pokemon go plus
plus device
[Music]
and next we turn to the latest updates
about Pokemon scarlet and Pokemon Violet
the newest games in the Pokemon series
which were released in November last
year
[Music]
foreign
have been found in the paldaya region
it seems walking wake appears in Pokemon
Scarlet
while iron leaves can be found in
Pokemon violet
[Music]
you'll be able to catch them for
yourself by claiming victory in a terror
Raid Battle event the event will begin
not long after this broadcast as soon as
preparations are complete
we hope you'll team up with family
friends and other trainers to take on
this challenge
[Music]
the games will also soon be able to
connect to Pokemon go
in Pokemon go you can receive gifts from
friends or by visiting pokestops around
the world
these gifts come with postcards
once it's possible to connect these
games you'll be able to send postcards
to your Pokemon Scarlet or Pokemon
Violet game and you'll find that the
pattern of Vivion that appear there will
change based on the postcard's location
data and on the Pokemon Go Side the
players who have sent postcards will
find themselves able to catch roaming
form gimme ghoul in that game
try to collect 999 gimme ghoul coins to
evolve gimme ghoul into golden go
we're also planning to begin Pokemon
home support for Pokemon scarlet and
Pokemon Violet early this year
[Music]
then you'll be able to bring roaming
form gimme ghoul that you've caught in
Pokemon go to Pokemon scarlet and
Pokemon Violet via Pokemon home
we hope you look forward to it
and finally we'd like to share our last
video for today with you
please have a look at this
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
DLC will be available for purchase for
the Pokemon scarlet and Pokemon Violet
games
the title of this DLC is the hidden
treasure of area zero
the hidden treasure of area 0 will be
released in two parts with part one the
teal mask coming in Fall 2023
part 2 the Indigo disc will be
distributed in Winter 2023 purchasing
the hidden treasure of area 0 will allow
you to enjoy playing both parts of the
DLC with the saved data you already have
in Pokemon Scarlet or Pokemon violet
in part one the teal mask you'll be
visiting the land of kitakami as part of
a school trip as your adventures expand
beyond the paudia region
and in part two the Indigo disc you'll
be studying as an exchange student at
Blueberry Academy
[Music]
during these Adventures you'll be able
to encounter some familiar Pokemon that
you didn't see living in paldea
the legendary Pokemon that newly appear
in the hidden treasure of area zero are
ogrepon with its fearsome mask
and teropogos resplendent in its
glittering Aura please look forward to a
new story that will unfold in two parts
as you discover the roles that both
these Pokemon will play in your
adventures
the hidden treasure of area 0 will be
available for purchase on Nintendo eShop
shortly after this presentation ends
as soon as you make your purchase you'll
be able to get the new uniform set and
Don some new outfits in your Pokemon
Scarlet or Pokemon Violet game
as an early purchase bonus we've also
prepared a serial code that will allow
you to claim a special hisuian Zora Arc
for your in-game team
[Music]
we hope you enjoy these expanded
adventures in the Pokemon scarlet and
Pokemon Violet games
[Music]
what did you think
as we move forward
we'll keep trying to find new ways to
bring the joy of Pokemon to you all
thank you for tuning in
[Music]